good morning Hank it's Friday I'm gonna
do Alex this YouTube survey today but
quickly four things first of all you
said balls a lot in your last video
second team six for life third our
secret sister Maureen Johnson aka actual
John Green had her best book ever at the
name of the star come out yesterday I am
very excited about this book because
everybody is gonna love it for think did
you know that nerdfighters have blown
more than 55 thousand dollars to
entrepreneurs in the developing world
through Kiva French the llama $55,000
Hank I'm once again reminded that
nerdfighters are made of Awesome so
every year Alex Day does a survey well
this is the first year but it's you know
gonna be every year I lost about your
first case I assume you mean french-kiss
in that case who was at summer camp
summer camp was kind of like the
internet before the internet was the
Internet like it's summer camp you were
cooler and better looking than you were
IRL thank you might have heard the story
before but I had a girlfriend her name
was Tiffany and we had a candlelight
ceremony on the last night of camp hey
looking back I'm not even sure I would
technically call it kissing was kind of
like facial licking but anyway we had
this candlelight ceremony and we both
knew that we wanted to French we
discussed it previously everybody's
crying cuz cancer about the end you got
to go back to your IRL life where you
aren't nearly as cool and I walk up to
Tiffany and I wrap my arms around her
and I start you know just licking her
face
and eventually I start to smell the fact
that my hair is on fire because I got my
arm so far wrapped around her the candle
was like lighting my hair and it's
burning and yeah my second kiss came
three years later most expensive cash
for lights McCleary thing ever bull
definitely this suit which I had to buy
so I wouldn't look like a dumbass
standing next to my wife at the venice
biennale of course next i will say that
this suit isn't casual in which case my
most expensive article of casual
clothing is probably my team six for
life t-shirt what was the first job you
ever won't sit as a kid I don't know if
you remember this Aang but when we were
little I really wanted to be an
earthworm scientist like a professional
studier of earthworms I guess because it
mixed my two talents of animal husbandry
in science and thus about Joe grupos
girlfriend I was a nerd but then for my
last three years of high school I went
to a really nerdy boarding school and
there I wasn't really a nerd I was kind
of like a troublemaker I'm so
embarrassed
this secret non nerdy past what would
you name your kids how do you know
you're too old for YouTube you've
already named a kid I really wanted to
name henry gatsby but say i was like we
can't name our child gatsby she was like
he's a tragic character you don't want a
child to end up like gatsby but i was
like no no no Gatsby turned out alright
in the end it was what preyed on Gatsby
what foul dust trailed in the wake of
his dreams I actually wanted to put that
quote over his create but who do you
want to answer the survey next everybody
can leave survey responses here or at
near mons video but I really want my
brother to answer this survey my brother
Hank green whom I will see on Monday my
chair so spinning its spinny spinny
chair a promise nerdfighteria I wouldn't
sing anymore I'm sorry